Rodney hood off to a great start eg
hurry back to the other way launches and
hits that Penta three on the way up well
that's how they function though yep
drive and dump that was nice woman that
sure was the three seconds left curry
came wide open that's one of the sluice
box he drains it Dory from straight on
he's a 49% shooter from there come on
Larry Nance Jr now in the middle for the
Cavs the parking lot get down from
Willow ik that's one thing he makes you
have to do and five guys moving but
anything in the gym is fair game
first up Curt the guy's head into pit
Kotetsu you can go after that pass curry
knocks lon turn around
knocks it back how much you can do about
that no that's a bad shot for most
humans but for curry in there absolutely
good job of taking advantage of a a lazy
gold safety pin curry gets it back
though for three oh boy
so you never know where it's coming from
67-66
hurry backs out and drills that 3-ball
those the kind of chances is hard to
defend themself they miss you got asked
old man he's good shot curry totalized
and he sticks it into his family so it's
a two for curry looking for the n1 Pryor
shot was not going to be reviewed either
curry again like a layup for him
[Applause]